a long-awaited massive invasion of
cicadas
is now swarming large areas of the east
and midwest and these little bugs can be
deafening
that's what they sound like but if
they're anywhere near you we don't have
to tell you that this group of insects
is called brood 10 and it emerges from
the ground every 17 years
the swarms are so big in the baltimore
washington area
that they show up on national weather
service radar
good news is they won't stick around
much longer ben tracy shows us what the
bugs are doing while they're here
and how the rest of us are coping
in the backyard of jessica helms
maryland home we were getting over
2 000 a day it is peak cicada season
her six-year-old olivia started counting
them we found
many bugs but quickly ran out of fingers
and then buckets then we had to
cicada shells cover the ground and hang
from the trees
and while all of this may terrify many
adults
you think i'm kind of lame yes i do
olivia is now invested in these insects
giving the cicadas names
and rides on all of her toys we are
surrounded by
cicadas we are surrounded by not just
the cicadas
but their sound from every direction
sammy ramsey is an entomologist at the
u.s department of agriculture
he's also known as dr bugs cicada season
has been
so exciting pretty much all the cicadas
that exist are out of the ground
and they are in the treetops this is the
symphony
section of the experience the cicadas
are now letting themselves be heard
dr bugs says it's just the males making
all that noise
at levels that rival a garbage disposal
or vacuum cleaner
they are trying to attract female
cicadas which have notoriously high
standards
they get the chance to sit around and
say um i don't like him i don't like him
i don't like him that one
i like him for the next four weeks the
cicadas will fulfill their 17-year
mission
mating in the trees to produce the next
generation while trying to avoid getting
eaten by a bird
before they do it truly a majestic
existence
are you sure you're a scientist at the
usda
dr bugs isn't the only one enjoying
cicada mania
these odd-looking insects are inspiring
art
fashion and music
a brewery in virginia created a cicada
beer
and named it brood x no cicadas were
harmed in the making of this beer
which is perfect for washing down a
crunchy cicada taco you'd expect the guy
wearing this
to enjoy eating that but at this
restaurant in leesburg virginia
they're selling 30 orders of cicada
tacos
every day about 50 percent of those that
come in
order a second round of tacos tobias
potavano is the chef
those look tasty i do see little cicada
eyes looking at me
yeah they're yeah they're gonna look at
you they'll judge you and then it was
time for my first bon appetit
bug bite crunchy nutty that's pretty
good
so our anchor gale king really wants to
eat some cicadas
okay can you send her a couple of these
oh most definitely
unfortunately after waiting 17 years the
cicada's moment of glory
is fleeting they are here for a good
time not a long time
dr bugg says both the males and the
females will die off after mating
the eggs the females lay in the trees
will fall to the ground
and the 17-year cycle starts all over
are you going to be sad to see them go
ben i cannot describe to you the just
the sense of dread
that is already in my heart knowing that
i am not going to be able to experience
this again
until i am in my 40s that's perspective
and so we soon say farewell to brood 10.
we'll see you in 2038 for cbs this
morning ben tracy
washington tracy i'm officially nauseous
right now
yeah i'll stick with frosted flakes
bananas for a thousand dollars i would
not eat a cicada time no definitely not
50
of the people come back for seconds the
other 50 run
right out the door oh no you know tony
you made a good point what's better than
a cicada taco one that comes in the mail
they're gonna send it to you again you
can open it up wait a minute
there it is it's a cat beer though that
i contract and love me some dr
bugs you are terrific sir fun to watch